bienvenue dans le cirque le plus dangereux de
la saison la tension électrique ici frissonne
jusqu'à présent l'histoire de deux hommes exténuants
et incroyablement dramatiques la saison réduit
le match de rancune de course de la décennie
la rivalité James Hunt Niki Lauda est l'un
des plus grands péchés tous les sports leur
l'histoire est si remarquable que vous ne pouvez le
faire que c'était vrai parce que les gens
ne le croiraient pas tout à fait Nicky Hager
et James Hutton côte à côte une
bataille incroyable entre ces deux
grands pilotes que le film suit
jusqu'à la fin de 1976  saison où la
rivalité arrive à une tête dramatique gagne
vous pouvez sentir que je respire dans votre
cou la
prochaine fois que je t'aime l'une des choses
qu'ils disent à propos de cette période des années 70 dans le
monde de la Formule 1, c'est que c'est quand le sexe était
sûr et la conduite était dangereuse  Je sauf
qu'à chaque fois que j'arrive à La Mecque, il y a 20% de
chances que je meure Niki l'a abordé de la manière la plus
rationnelle et la plus professionnelle
possible où James Hunt était un
homme à femmes flamboyant, on m'a dit que
vous étiez  un mauvais garçon il a vécu une vie de
rock and roll mais avait le talent de
se mettre quand même dans la voiture et d'aller comme l'
enfer
me parler James ne soyez pas l'
étranger n'y allez pas trop étaient prêts à se
suicider cercles de conduite  à la recherche de la
normalité, l'un des aspects fascinants
de cette histoire est que l'intrépidité
que ces gars avaient comme des chevaliers modernes
leur faisant constamment face je suis plus rapide que
vous tous bien
faisons la course cette volonté de gagner conduisait
ces deux gars et que toutes sortes de
ont atteint leur paroxysme au cours d'une saison 1976,
ils étaient prêts à risquer leur vie pour
conserver ce statut d'élite, ils en ont payé le
prix, ils en ont payé le prix,
mais ils se définissent, je me sens
responsable de ce qui s'est passé
me battre pour ma vie tu étais également
responsable de me ramener dans la
voiture c'est une question d'amitié à
propos de la peur surmonter la peur des rivaux
qui se poussent au-delà des limites
je me trompe champion au-dessus de la fusion pour
devenir monde  champion à nouveau, je peux battre
ce gars, croyez-moi,
c'est un film que je voulais voir et le
monde que je voulais occuper et partager
avec le public, non seulement à cause du
drame sans piste, le drame de la vie et de la mort,
c'est aussi juste la nature vraiment vraiment
divertissante de  ces deux gars,
vous savez, ils sont tous les deux fascinants,
ils sont drôles, ils sont sérieux et
formidables et la combinaison de ces
gars, leur rivalité, leurs relations
hors piste ainsi que la façon dont ils se sont
comportés pour essayer d'être
géniaux, je pensais  émotionnel cool et
certainement fascinant plus vous êtes proche
de la mort plus vous vous sentez vivant c'est une
merveilleuse façon de vivre c'est la seule façon
de vous conduire